okay it is
october which means
it is spooky time and i'm a big old
scaredy cat when it comes to horror
games so it's gonna be a great month for
me my webcam i'm trying to make it
spooky it probably looks silly uh but we
are playing a game called inscription
very big thank you to i think i have to
do this
just just that just what do you want me
to do
um continue
i don't have a save
that seems strange
um devolver digital gave me a code this
is my first time playing it we're gonna
jump through the first hour
and i know virtually nothing about it
well
i don't love that immediately
okay
perhaps you've forgotten how this game
is played
allow me to remind you oh that's some
nice bass
play the squirrel cod
okay
now play your stoat
i don't know what that means
oh
blood sacrifices must be made that makes
sense
so we're going to kill the squirrel to
play the stoke
okay
wolves require two sacrifices you don't
have enough ring the bell to end your
turn and commence combat all right
oh it's music your stoat stands on a
post
the number on the bottom left is attack
power
all right it's pretty standard card game
stuff which is not what i was expecting
here
just don't dump me one damage i added it
to the scale
okay got it i understand
oh
he's got a spooky hand
okay
stoke stands in the way of my coyote
um it has more attack power but i would
live through the attack
yes
if a creature's health reaches zero it
dies that tracks i'm familiar okay is
this what this game's gonna be i did not
expect this
you may draw from your deck or you may
draw a squirrel
i should probably draw a squirrel
i think
harsh but fair and then we need to
sacrifice the squirrel to play a wolf i
think so
oh okay we gotta kill both of them
and then play the wolf
and then wolf attack
right i can't do anything else yeah okay
oh i just have to end my time
great okay
a random card from your deck or the
certainty of a squirrel i'm gonna random
card this time
river snapper hmm
well i'd have to i can't i can't play
anything so
[Music]
that's convenient you passing for me is
actually pretty great thank you for that
that's all i can do unless what does the
river snapper do is my question oh
that's a big boy
doesn't you got a lot of help there
but i don't want to
no no we're gonna pass
how are you still alive oh thank you
you know what i have
okay
this base is like banging
all right
i was lost deep in the forest
a single path revealed itself
okay
two denzens of the forest approach you
tentatively
the caustic adder damage from its poison
bite is always lethal
the undying cat sacrificing the poor
beast does not kill it
only one may grace your paltry deck
i'm gonna go the cat
because it seems different
cool
okay some of the creatures of the forest
seemed willing to follow you
you came across an abandoned sack
you found a squirrel in a bottle break
it in case of emergency that's
interesting
and have a second
another useful important it'll allow you
to tip the scales with it oh that's cool
three is as much as you can carry
okay
we're gonna go play another game now i
assume
you're ambushed while crossing some
rough terrain
i'm sorry buddy
i'm sorry my friend
interesting this is super cool
um okay you may now see my moves ahead
of time that sounds great
but what do i what i want to play right
now is this any of this mind no this is
just stuff on the board now
well
okay i need to play and kill a squirrel
wolf cub huh
a card bearing this sigil will grow into
a more powerful form after one turn on
the board interesting okay
noted
okay
um so we gotta kill the squirrel and
play
the stoat
look at that can we play him here
no
he's gonna grow stronger but i'm gonna
have to kill one of these
i can do that though let's put you
here damn it
um but then sacrifice you to play that
is that the right
call i can play the cat
all right and i really just want to
break that stump but maybe that ain't my
problem
i'm not gonna kill two sacrifices right
now i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna
get it
okay
mine the ambitious wolf cub it ages
swiftly
it hasn't aged yet though um most girls
please play the squirrel
i'm gonna kill the squirrel
to play
the rip of snappo
you need to kill two things
okay
great cool looks good i feel good about
it
i don't need you yet
cool
oh no just a big old wolf the airborne
bat flies over creatures to attack
directly
that makes sense
i bat flip right over your river snapper
the river snap is okay though right it
is um
draw a card
now i have wolf
i don't really want to sacrifice two
things flying is a [ __ ]
i mean i could kill the start
yeah yeah we're gonna do it
i'm sorry buddy it's
i need more wolf you know what i mean
it's
yeah okay we gotta pause
okay
that's good that seems good there's good
things are happening
neither of these are really useful to me
right now
i can't really do anything i could take
you and play you
and we still can't get this new wolf so
let's boom boom that seems good
squirrel it is i'm out of clouds well
it's so either right
okay
you prevailed and trekked onwards past
now bloody to terrain this is really
cool um i i mean i've always loved card
games i did not know this was going to
be a cod game but this is like a very
different
spooky vibe
i'm into it
okay
mm-hmm want flying
that does sound cool and we've just seen
both of it but i'm gonna go with the
sparrow because i want a flying card
i've played magic the gathering okay
you stumbled into some strange stones in
the mist
you are compelled to choose a worthy
sacrifice one that we lost forever
[Music]
i don't love that i just had to do that
a healthy host
okay it's gonna level somebody up
he wants me to pick him so i'm going to
that might have been a bad idea but i
like
i'm liking the story okay
now he has flying
whoa
cool
okay
what is this what is this what have you
done behold my totem it inscribes my
canine cards with airborne
dude
where do i get a totem
you see that right yeah
no care for the rules
pathetic really i think we probably keep
the stone around because he has sass
oh
sorry about that
well we're gonna play you
or can i not oh oh um okay i can play
the squirrel i can also pick up another
squirrel
right no
um
so we're gonna play the start again
boom
start
yes king
good luck to ya and then we have
skip
off to a great start
the
coyote is the power of flight i hate
that i hate that for me i hate all of
that that was so bad how did you play
all those damn you
squirrel
play the squirrel
play the cat
kill squirrel to play the cat
it's not great
it's not great but
oh my how are you getting all these big
oh boy jeez boy howdy g heck
dang
using this is a learning opportunity may
be the only way to mitigate my
disappointment get up
get up from the table
fetch me a candlestick from oh
okay
i didn't expect this
fetch me the candlestick from atop the
barrel beside the door
this this one oh god
oh god
oh oh oh god
oh
this
okay okay okay i will okay
oh
this is the least this
[ __ ]
hey bud i got you the candlestick
okay okay do you need it over here
for some weird reason do you
specifically need it from here
i didn't like that at all
i was not a fan
okay
okay i got you a candlestick
that's what you wanted
let me explain something to you
that was one of the two mistakes that i
can make
you gonna kill me
if i
play cards bad
okay
oh there's a choice that's interesting
all right what do we got bullfrog
leaps in the way of attacking flyers
that's interesting okay
the elk it moves after attacking
huh
the wolf
what does that mean
i already have a wolf
i don't know the function of the elk
just yet i'm gonna go with the bullfrog
because in the immediate it feels like
it will help me okay what is this
oh geez
that's another
no i don't know what that is campfire
seems friendly let's go with the
campfire
came across a small group of survivors
faces shrunken from starvation they
huddled around a campfire
they looked upon your group of creatures
and beckoned
come warm one of your creatures by the
fire why did i say that like that i said
it warm one of your creatures
come warm one of your creatures by the
fire i thought they were calling me warm
one
warm it by the fire that will enhance
its power okay
you notice one of the survivors wiping
drool from their mouth oh
should i trust them then or
i think i should
who do i want to level up and am i
giving them
bite
or something
the river snapper having more attack
seems handy so does the cat though
because i keep using the cat
oh no you don't don't you eat my cat no
without a word you pull the cat away
from the fire and left these well i was
gonna call them cannibals but that would
imply that they are cats
i feel good about the campfire decision
it was creepy
but i am repeatedly playing the cat so
giving the cat attack at least for one
round
seems handy that said i probably could
have used it to make a tankier card
there's a way out for both of us it's
somewhere in this foul cabin
okay
cool
good to know uh what do we got
grand fur that's a flying tree
grizzly dude you how your cards get so
good so fast
oh i forgot about that
um
okay we're gonna play the squirrel
because it's the best thing to do and
then we'll play this
kill
play
no
no i'm not i'm not i'm really sorry
did i do a bad
yeah
yeah
yeah that would happen wouldn't it all
right well we're screwed now um
so that's my b
a squirrel
i could just leave you there to take the
hit but i would like to be able to play
the cat so we're just going to put the
cat over here for now [ __ ] that we're
going to take six though
oh gee oh heck god dang
it's my grandfather
hmm
all right
okay
oh it hurts oh it oh it hurts so bad
you know
oh
okay
i'm gonna play the wolf
am i killing the cat squirrel i'm gonna
put him
[ __ ]
he'll die immediately
but
what if i could just take another one
and i don't know how much health i
actually have should i use this
i ripped a tooth out of my own mouth
i thought that it would just like put
weight on it
oh my god
okay
and only one point
i might just die here anyway
oh
oh well the scales continue though so if
i do a lot of damage in a round
hmm cat
shrivel snapper i don't want to get rid
of my [ __ ] wolf dude
not for you no no we messed up i should
have taken can i put it back
[ __ ]
i think this is the end i think that i
made mistakes
no it's actually pretty equal right now
squirrel because we're doing similar
amounts of damage so play squirrel
kill squirrel
killed cat
he
be okay
i don't well he can't
i wish i could
it was a bad idea
and because i just immediately done it
that was also stupid but
it's not like i'd be able to play that
anyway
yeah okay
okay i don't feel like i made good
choices there i'm a bit panicked
so
there's that all right
another cat a bullfrog or a sparrow
hmm
i'm gonna go with another cat and i'm
just gonna try and level up the cat
again
campfire right we level up another cat
are you gonna try and eat my cat too get
your eyes out of it get your eyes out of
it a group of starving survivors stood
around a dying campfire
there is room for a creature around the
fire once said
the warmth will enhance its power said
another
one of the survivors said nothing at all
but could not stop licking their lips
it cheeses the cards for me though
doesn't it
oh no okay it's everything so cat one or
cat two
because
you're all a bit [ __ ]
two cats that can do damage i think is
good
we are leveling up the cats the power of
the cat was enhanced by the warmth
as one of the survivors began pulling a
knife from their pocket you withdrew
oh okay
okay
okay cool
okay the trees seem to close in around
you as
as a chill miss descended
in the distance you could hear the
clinking of metal on the stone that's
not that distant that's actually quite
present that's in the immediate
a hubbled figure stood in your path
[Music]
oh god okay towards the prospector
he's doing the prospector again easy
boss the mule's key oh this is a boss
okay
he's actually kind of less scary now he
looks kind of nice so i'm alright with
it
um
well we play our squirrel
[Music]
and we play our cat
and we can't play our stoked just yet we
would have to get got to play stoked we
can okay
um can't afford the river snapping out
there right we have to kill
two of them which i don't want to do
okay
pack mule
what does it do
uh we're gonna draw a squirrel
we're gonna play a squirrel
we're gonna play red snapper by killing
squirrel and cat
great let's go
seems great so far
yeah please attack my bowler what do i
care
um
i can't play anyone without a squirrel
but whatever
can't play a wolf
without killing cat and the river
snapper
and i don't really want to play the wolf
because
you know
but it's not
he has so many card
they only do one damage each no i feel
like i need to skip
four now okay
i hope you didn't think it would be that
easy i have to kill you twice
okay
who
who told you you could do that
that hardly seems fair
what the hell dude
can i sacrifice the gold nuggets
what do you expect me to do
can i i would like this please
can i stand up
this doesn't seem fair at all
damn okay
oh well you can get rid of them if you
want
that's fine you're just gonna keep
killing my squirrels though [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't
i can't do there's nothing
what was i supposed to do what was i
supposed to do
what was i supposed to do i don't know
what you expected me to do
oh no
okay
oh god oh god okay
you aren't dead yet this isn't purgatory
though you may think of it that way
before you expire i must ask you a favor
i would like a memento
all right
he gave me a gift and i was
scared it's quite plain at the moment
isn't it
we will work together to amend that
i want this to be the perfect memento of
you
here are some cards from your mediocre
deck you're not wrong
we can put them to good use please
choose a card to draw the cost from
while they're the same card
oh i'm making one
power and health
we would go with the river snapper
now choose a card from which you will
extract the sigils well is that the same
also
that's actually
pretty handy
oh i'm hey i'm alana
hit me
oh dang
okay okay okay
oh
[Music]
you really blew the camera out
[Music]
okay
i feel like i will be able to do better
now
and i do really
feel like i should walk around
resourceful opposite costs two
bones a bone in one of your creatures
perishes from for any reason okay
okay that's handy okay i like that
that's good we can use that
um
should play as girl
and we can play the stoic by killing
this girl
from the death creature you've gained a
bone
okay
that's great
your turn [ __ ]
but that's another bone isn't it um so i
can play the opposing
i don't play squirrel
and i'll pause
another squirrel
blade squirrel
killed squirrels
hmm that's cool
this game's neat all right
piece of candy
um okay
oh
i forgot your figurine
get up and fetch it for me
okay
this is my least favorite part of this
game
all right
besides
is that a hand
that's very intriguing i'm gonna figure
that out at some point aren't i okay um
oh well that one looks most like me but
i guess you need this one
no we're taking it
okay
elk squirrel
why are they there i wonder
oh yeah i still don't really
fully understand those return cards
either and that's gonna be able to open
at some point
what is this
okay can't take that yet whatever it is
hey bud just hanging out just looking at
it don't mind me
just looking at stuff can i open the
door
no
all right this is kind of exciting there
is going to be a way out of here you
just don't know what it is yet
oh what is what was that
oh
no let me pick that back up mighty leap
a card bearing the sigil will block an
opposing creature
i kind of don't want to read them yet i
kind of want to
learn organically you know what i'm
saying
let us continue
okay
coyote but did you expect only four buns
that's easy four bones we now know is
easy the rattler a brutal creature once
passed it's 20 fangs
untouchable cockroach it returns your
hand up dying hmm
um
i think i'm gonna go with the rattler i
want a big damage boy that's so handy
though having something without a sigil
seems a little bit silly doesn't it
hmm
i can always level it up
i have just have so many that do so
little damage
i'm
you know you're free to get up again
to keep your blood flowing
i yeah but i don't
i haven't identified anything i can do
yet
okay
great
cut up one of my cards with these okay
black goat
it's bleeding yields three blood if you
can ignore the bleating
oh
that's cool okay oh i have to pick
i'm gonna go blackout
feeling of a burden with a full three
items you carried on
let's dance prince let's dance
i'm feeling good are you smart or
something he usually doesn't even bother
teaching about bones
all right here's a tip i saw a past
victim
writing a passcode in the rulebook ah
that's good to know thank you for that i
really appreciate that
play
motto
play
how is that a
misplay check
uh can't afford the review
continue
i probably should have put it in front
of the wolf cup
he does get stronger per round
uh we will take a squirrel and we will
play a squirrel
and we will
kill a squirrel to play a bull frog
yep
cool
alpha what does that mean
uh we will take another squirrel
to play a squirrel
how many do i have i don't know but i
can't afford this yet um well let me see
what the alpha does
what does he do
what do you do sir
okay well i find out after we finish the
round
harsh but fair
um another squirrel for you my friend
enjoy yourself
you should be pretty much dead
i got unlimited squirrels boss man i can
do this all day
there we go
how brutal of you
you dealt me more damage than you needed
to win
however in my game such feats are
rewarded to be precise a tooth to keep
for each extra damage dealt the trapper
may be interested in your spoils
i don't know what that means but i would
like to stand up
i am no tyrant you may stand whenever
the map is unrolled it allows me time to
plan your next encounter but do keep
your hands up my possessions oh it's his
hut
noted i will not keep my hands up your
possessions oh that's a 27 273.
i think that's it 273.
oh my god there's a lot going on in here
ooh that sounds great i like that
all right 273
don't mind
me good sir
two
i'm not sure if there's a better way to
do this
i think i have to do it damn it i missed
seven
seven
three
stink bug what does that do oh hello
i wasn't sure if i would ever escape
that iron crypt
is the stout around the stunted wolf
this madness must end
is he mad at me oh did he move
no he's still there
i don't feel like this is a good
i idea like i'm gonna get in trouble for
this i don't feel like
what the [ __ ]
this is like its own game
huh
interesting
what would it mean
i'm gonna say
maybe
i'm not meant to touch that just yet
is my guess
i will see if i get more hints okay
new card
beehive
when it is attacked you will draw a bee
what a bees do
hit me
i'm gonna take me
look at me go okay
that gives me an item i'm full
that
gives me a sigil for a car that doesn't
have a sigil and that levels up a cod
we like the level ups
i'm gonna do it again
hello my friends the warm light of a
campfire was a welcome sight
though the ten hungry guys around it
dampened the greeting
warmer creature by the fire and ends its
power said one
yes
pick something else okay
i could enhance alana
it only enhances power though
and she's already
i think she's already pretty pretty good
um the wolf maybe i don't know who do i
want to enhance right now the rattler
a lot yeah a lot is already pretty op
i don't know let's do the odd possum
oh it was attack my bad i should have
that's how did i already forget that
that fast i should have done that but
it's fine
they enhanced the creature's power
spotting a few of the survivors drooling
you made the hasty retreat with your own
possum
it is pronounced opossum right we don't
have oat possums in australia they only
have possums and they're very cute
whereas the american ones are hideous
all right let's play ponyboy
it
there's another ally
uh we're playing this girl
as always we can play the bullfrog by
sacrificing
the squirrel you got a coyote and a wolf
cup i'll put you here
and then
yeah
your turn pony boy
not my favorite squirrel
go boy oh
kill the squirrel
play this dog
i love him he's great
what is he what does that mean
um all right
um that was actually the wrong idea i
should have drawn a card
let me put you there anyway
i can play the stinkbug
beautiful what did you say back in the
game
welcome
oh god
oh possum can already be played
good stuff
i think that might be it for you
[Music]
no
um
i'm gonna do card again
alana cannot yet be played
all right great cool great great great
love that
all right new card let's go
this is dope i'm really into this game
and i am definitely unsettled okay
beehive kaminsky
damn kaminsky got game
the
apothecized black goat the truest
offering sacrificing it grants three
blood that's pretty good
that was an accident i didn't mean to do
that
i didn't mean to do that i was trying to
read it and then i
took it into my deck i now behind
[ __ ] up
i really just made
a big mistake why does my chin
look so orange oh it's because of the
light
behind me i made myself a little bit
opaque
because i thought it would be more
spooky
i [ __ ] up
it's fine
it's fine
it's fine it's
fine
back to the campfire we love it here we
love it out here we're having a great
time oh i should have seen what was in
the list though
yes
i guess i'll walk the [ __ ] a shitty
[ __ ] beehive [ __ ] what does it even
do
it's probably pretty dope um i could
also do alana
do what you must he really doesn't like
it
doesn't like it
um let's do let's do alana i think we're
gonna do alana
there you go queen just as you deserve
yes queen
yes
oh my god um lady boss
you suspected the intentions of the
survivors were less than pure ew it's
like it has a different context when
it's me i don't like that at all with
your elana in tow you're attracted into
the woods
nice a lot of nice all right this one
gives me
uh oh oh
oh
we didn't have a great time with this
last time
why can't i remember his name i believe
i lost some of my memory
in the flash
all right
what you got up here boss everything can
fly
and that's the worst um
we're gonna play a squirrel cheeky
squirrel we're gonna play a bullfrog a
cheeky bullfrog
we cannot play anything else so we're
going to boss
oh that's a lot of flying coyotes i
wonder what that looks like
and i can actually sacrifice the
squirrel
for the stick bug
oh i can play it anyway because i have
the
the cards what did he say good play oh
thank you he's much nicer
um
yeah i gotta skip
look
there's a third talking card somewhere
around here
personally i hate the guy
biggest killjoy ever
but he's the only one of us with a plan
to get things
back to normal what does back to normal
mean
i will play you my
friend
keep me alive i'd love to
you
have more faith in me than i do we do
not have six bones
that gave us an extra bun
um okay well
i'm not feeling great i'm not feeling
great i'm not feeling great you know
what
free squirrel i think we should take the
free squirrel
though i have to take a card anyway
don't i
god
alana hello
my good friend
we could kill one of these two
and we'd also take the black goat i
i i
i'm gonna i'm gonna do both i'm gonna do
both i'm gonna play i'm gonna okay we're
gonna wait we're gonna put squirrel out
we're gonna play the blackout
we're going to sacrifice the black goat
for an alana
and we can't yet play the rattler but we
got closer i feel okay with it
oh god
okay
squirrel no
god
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
the wolf
is technically better than both of you
so i really really i should
i'm sorry my friend i should kill both
of you
the stinkbug will go back in my deck is
that what that was i don't remember and
now i can play the router great
that one's gotta hurt
yeah
that was good i liked it
and i got owned on that round last time
good stuff okay new card let's not press
the wrong thing this time
the industrious beaver when played it
can
constructs dams adjacent to it
that's interesting
beehive don't know what it does
lewis
you just got
[ __ ] louis okay
i'm gonna go with the beaver
lewis is pretty cheap though
but um
biba
all right
this is me putting a sigil on somebody
all right let's do it what were they
different
do they do different things
i think maybe the top one i don't know
who do i want to level up here i mean
i'll go okay
that's what he wanted
uh beehive
wait that would be me giving him the
beehive sigil
yeah that's fine
because he lost the previous one right
because i died
i don't know what it has though um can i
look at
what is it
not that
it is not that it is
i don't remember what it even looks like
unfortunately
is there a way for me to look at my
cards outside of the inside of the game
i don't think there is
i don't think there is
i would like to see my deck i don't feel
like i'm ready for this
well alrighty prospector again
oh no oh my
my boss battles are high stakes tests of
your aptitude
with one flame you will either overcome
them
or die
fear not i will let you keep the smoke
oh
the incessant clank clank clanking
reverberated between your ears
the part the head was blocked by a
grotesque figure
this is prospector and he's still kind
of cute
i don't think he's grotesque at all
i kind of like him
okay playing the squirrel
what is this what do you do
oh my [ __ ] idea oh can i can i read
it what do you what do you do tell me
what you do
uh
we can't play anybody except for you
and
yep and yep
what the smoke do
the smoke maybe was
oh
[Music]
easy bones got it okay
all right
[Music]
i'll take a squirrel
and i won't kill a squirrel
i don't want to kill the bullfrog right
now though we can play the outpost
we'll keep the beaver for now
okay
okay cop
wolf we gotta kill somebody to have one
of you
really we should play the beaver kill
the opposite
and the bull frog
may have not
no no no i take it back i take back
everything
boy okay cool
oh no
everybody's dying
i'm gonna play a squirrel
i'm gonna play
the
beaver
[Music]
adjacent to me
i reckon we maybe put you
here
yeah that seems good
yeah
i gotta pause
okay
please be bones
[ __ ]
the top left draw
but the puzzle was too easy the top left
drawer of the wardrobe
all right that's good to know
shall we we shall uh i don't want to
kill either of you so we're gonna play
that voice
let's roll
[Music]
well i feel like i could kill the beaver
now to put the wolf out but i still have
so many butts points but
oh god
i didn't have done that
uh do i want to do that just you know in
case not really not really
i don't want to sacrifice either of you
i don't want to sacrifice you for me i'm
doing it i'm doing it just
pull a tooth out it's fine
oh
what and heck
oh
oh that's why they told me about the
mule last time oh well that changes
everything so long as i make it through
this which i will
i did not
i didn't
i didn't make it
okay
that's all right
we know about the mule now which is a
game changer
not this [ __ ] again
god damn it what are you gonna take
another picture of me
stay there no need to move i'm afraid
you are not dead yet
hold still
hmm why did i put that camera of mine
is here
i don't know what the camera is capable
of no
we have a memento to create
your death card shall we begin to ink it
yes
uh
draw cost is bullfrog
correct
power and health
is rattler
card from which we might extract sigils
is gonna have to be the beaver because
that's all we've got
um pierce
all right
let's roll
my visage
[Music]
nailed it
so blown out
it looked like the bottom half of my
face is stand
alright buddy
yep bit me
you didn't
yeah i've got it now though
i'm ready to go
i understand
okay
cool
are you telling me i have to pick one of
these
no
all righty oh you caught new new new
thing this disney
you may not choose a specific beast
you must decide now
on a tribe that you prefer a tribe
what is this supposed to be
i feel like i'm gonna go with the deer
oh
hooved card i see
um yeah sort of black code's pretty
handy though i'll take it it's cool we
like it we're all right with it
okay what is this some kind of
raven being killed an ancient woman
emerged from behind an oak tree
she carefully laid out intricate wood
carvings then jested at them bruce lee i
don't know what that word means
sexily oh look at how good
um
i like those
i'm gonna go with them
you accepted the wood carver's offering
it is useless without its second half
but you intuited that this would not be
the last encounter with her
cool
let's go
eagle [ __ ]
these ones get pretty spicy pretty quick
but we can make it work
hmm
we played this don't
and
now we'll let you live
it is pretty dumb that i have an
attachment to the character cards to be
fair
it's not my smartest
um
am i gonna draw
which i probably shouldn't have done
but i have
so we will
sorry but
play the black guard we will
sacrifice the black goat
before that and then play this as well
damn
okay
i think i like made a horrible mess of
that my brain just wasn't even
processing what i was doing
so that's what just happened
i can't stop thinking about that
wardrobe the metal sliders they're
they're a bit like cards aren't they
okay so i can do that then i'm gonna go
to they'll go to that one next time
would you say cracking
roll
harsh
but fair
squirrel plate
squirrel murder wolfram mata wolf play
oh i really would have thought that
would be it well just play a squirrel
just for fun you know sometimes just
[ __ ] around play squirrel
okay
cool
um
all right you want me to get up and you
want me to come
to this
i don't have cards though so
i'm not super clear on what i'm supposed
to do
you know
like
what is it
asking for me
is it asking for the scales to be even
because they can't be right
um
like what happens if i
do you want me to win
is that it like you need me down here
i'm unsure
this one's a little bit more elaborate
maybe it means these are the cards i
already have dealt and those are the
cards they already have dealt with then
why can i move them up and down
i really don't know
um
okay
zero five you need me to do five damage
to the other side of the scale
because again wouldn't you just
do that
that did zero
okay
not sure what that meant i forgot that i
put that card there very well you may
add it to your deck and i'll deal you
one every so often
a skink
okay what did you call me
alright
um
absolutely no damage
still absolutely no damage um
well you should be able to damage
whatever you want fam
um
we just have to get it to five but i'm
not really sure
i can't move them across or anything
do we need to do it from the other side
maybe
i'm sure this is like more complex than
my brain is making it out to be i'm
being real silly with this
i wonder if maybe there'll be another
piece for me to find
that's what i'm gonna bank on that maybe
there's something else to that
okay buddy
i hear you i see you let's go let's go
let's go we're almost at an hour this is
really fun i really like this
um
alrighty
what you got
i don't know what they do
i don't even know what this is meant to
be
flying is gonna be that right and i do
like the wall but i'm gonna go flying
cool
i will take a sparrow
that has to be
okay the old wood cover again appeared
before you
choose
a deer
a wolf
or a beetle
wolf
what cool totem have i made
a bone wolf the old woman beared her
teeth in satisfaction your first totem
was complete
the bone king sigil will now be marked
upon all your canine creatures oh great
i love that
that's i feel good about that
uh
this one
let's roll
oh the left would have been easier
wouldn't it whatever i guess
okay
great
we're a fan we are a fan
uh that means you've already got one i
can't play you just yet i don't have to
kill this king well
i could because that would be adding the
bones for the wolf but i won't
assuming that's that i'm right about
what the
the bones are going to do
i want to call it cowardly
hmm that's interesting
um
i guess
well yeah i may have just [ __ ] that up
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
don't worry about it i wanted to worry
about it you may have just made mistakes
but it's fine we all make mistakes
everybody makes mistakes
give me bones you are not bones oh
oh the game just crashed
no okay strange
um bullfrog no
no no no no no we'll play the sparrow
we can't play the sparrow either we can
pass
it's fine i can take that
i would just like to play bone cards i
don't have any that's right i'm playing
it like
i had the same deck as the last round
which is stupid that's my problem i'm
making a mistake i don't have phone
cards
um
so who do i have here that doesn't miss
damage
it's still the wolf
i
would like to be able to see my deck is
my thing
oh
that seems bad
you were stopped along the way by a
trapper looking to liquidate his pelts
there was something uncanny about his
appearance but you were quickly
distracted by his wares
care to look at me pelts
take a pelt free of charge
i have to take this one then don't i
see the quality
i do
i can pick any of these
i mean
i mean
oh it's about how many teeth i have i
thought you said i could take one free
of charge you [ __ ] punk
i have three
let's take the rabbit well no we'll take
the free one
okay
take that one
that's all i can afford
i don't know what those do
the man assured you the value of the
pelts they appear to be useless in a
fight but he mentioned that the traitor
further down the path would reward you
for them okay cool
campfire we love
that's the totem
backpack we're gonna go campfire again
we we are partial to
the crackling fire lit the starving
faces of a group of survivors we have
not food one set
but perhaps one of your creatures will
join us enhance its health said another
yeah dude let's give somebody more
health who would like more health
i
we'll go with the wolf actually
just make you a boss
the fire warmed the weary wolf and
enhanced its help you suspect the
intentions of the five survivors were
less than pure with your wolf in tow you
retreated into the woods
retreat with shad all right let's fight
ponyboy i'm ready let's go let's go
let's go i don't want to stop playing
this game technically this is the hour
mark i'm gonna wait till i fight the
prospector again all right
um
we should kill the wolf cup we should we
should we should
and pause
may you kill my squirrel oh god
thank you for that just what i wanted
okay
and another squirrel and play
the stink bug
here
thank you again i appreciate that it
really means a lot to me
what do you do why do you look like such
a butthole
um
regular cod rabbit pelt
it's not gonna do anything i think
right
oh
there goes a light
i should have used another squirrel i'm
playing as though i have the same
loadout every time and it's messing me
up
and it is my own fault i'm not ready
okay
choose not a specific beast but decide
the cost that you wish to pay
two blood three blood
i like to pay
bones a random card with a cost of a
bone
what were you expecting
i actually had no expectations so
consider me fulfilled
totem
i'm just gonna try and kill this goddamn
cross prospector man that's it
okay
[Music]
with gently shaking hands she placed her
offerings before you they are the same
interesting
they are not the same we could give
somebody flying i'm right with that
i don't know what it does is the problem
oh it would be upon death for bones
which was actually probably a bad call
i prefer that
that is gonna be
flying automatically all right prospect
let's [ __ ] do this let's [ __ ] [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up dude
i'm done with you
die
a chill is closed in around you you are
not alone
a figure emerged from the fog
stand in the way of me gold be donned
i just readjusted my camera there okay
we love to play a squirrel
and we can immediately play a sparrow so
let's do it to get the bones up
and continue he has no buell right no oh
the pack mill is there we just need to
get a little bit closer my friend
that's it that's it that's it
beautiful
we're just trying to get at that pack
mule
that is it
okay
[Music]
we will play and we will murder hey
squirrel
um wait i can't play you oh no i can't
because i haven't murdered the
girl
the tomb and then we play the stink bug
right here and then we attack the pack
mule right right right
not yet
close though he has mechanics i am
unfamiliar with
um well
treat you
i don't need a bullfrog right now
i just need the pack meal to die
still nothing
okay
oh boy
let's steal a squirrel
i do have that don't i
oh [ __ ] okay
um
okay okay
i don't know how to pop the meal i'm
trying
play you and which one of you should i
play realistically
we'll play the bullfrog
kill the squirrel play the bullfrog
i cannot play the stoat i realize it's
happening whenever i accidentally click
off screen
um i'd really like to kill the pacquiao
i'd really like to oh it has two health
left
that's the [ __ ] issue did i lose this
again
god
damn it
uh
uh
bones i don't know what rabbit pots do
still not a clue
oh god oh god
it's not looking great for me what are
you are you gonna do anything
yep we'll do that again
okay
[Music]
i can't murder a rabbit pelt um
does he do more damage not really uh
uh i still don't know what the stink
does either
ah
i'm gonna do it so i can put you here
it probably was a bad play i'm probably
gonna die
that was all right it was okay
i need to kill
you so bad
and i can't
[ __ ]
that's kind of it for me
just
just
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i was so sure i'd kill him this time you
know i was so [ __ ] sure
god damn it
i didn't realize the mule had that much
health and that i should have timed
things
differently
that is my fault that is my fault
also i really messed myself up that
whole round by thinking i had more bone
cards than i did
because of the previous round which is
my own fault i don't usually do that in
a rope like but hear me out
i'm trying i am trying
yeah
yeah
yep just let's just make my death card
just [ __ ] do it
draw costs we make real low they're all
the same anyway
yep
why would i want to do that definitely a
wolf that's actually great
yeah
sigil
this
one unkillable that's good
alana prime
that's a good alana
just take a picture it's fine it's fine
it's fine
yes
[Music]
all right does he look different
i will do better
um i actually am going to stop playing
here though as i said it's always the
first hour we've played an hour this
game rules i'm very into it i definitely
want to play more of it um i've made
mistakes but i'm also very curious about
the story
uh it's super neat so
thank you all for watching i will have
more
horror game plays up this very week
um the next one i'm doing i think will
be hass
house of ashes i said hassan ashes
it's a very different type of spooky
game but uh i will see you all then